this program is brought to you by Emory
University emeritus college retirement
seminar session too it's a very long
title for a very important day my name
is charity Crabtree many of you have
probably received emails from me at one
time or the other I'm postdoctoral
fellows / senior program coordinator at
the emeritus college and I've been there
for four years and this is a something
that we're really excited about because
we've never done a retirement seminar
quite like this so I hope that you've
been enjoying it if you were able to
come to the first session which was the
psychology of creative transitions to
retirement today obviously is the
creative approaches to healthy living in
retirement and we're lucky to have Lois
Richie which i will let professor Dalton
introduce her and then on the first of
March we're going to have one called
financial planning for Creative
retirement where we'll have Roger Ward
from Tarpley and Underwood associates
come and give us some ideas about ways
that we can plan creatively for
retirement hopefully that will be useful
before and after making that transition
and during so I do want to welcome you
then on behalf of the emeritus college
and I want to take just a second and
thank nan part let the director of the
emeritus college she'll raise her hand
there she doesn't like to raise her hand
very much but we like her anyway then
outside we had Issa Edwards she is a
program coordinator at the emeritus
college so I'm sure you got to meet her
and see her Pleasant smiling face we
also have some emeritus College members
here I wonder if those that are members
of the emeritus college could raise
their hand great so I'm glad you guys
could all come out and those of you who
are approaching that transition to
retirement this is what you have to look
forward to is being among this elite
group so if you have any questions about
it please feel free to ask and if they
respond coldly which I doubt then you
can come and see me and I will answer
your questions so this as I mentioned
this is the second of three retirement
seminar sessions the last one is
approaching capacity but if you'd like
to be registered we still have a few
spaces left so there's a registration
form outside on the table please feel
free to pick one up on your
out also we have these green evaluation
forms in your whole packet and I would
really appreciate as program coordinator
I'm going to put this plugin please
please take a moment to just fill those
out and let us know especially since
this is a new type of program how you
like it and how you think we might be
able to approve improve upon it I would
like to just take one more moment and
introduce the steering committee members
that we have here the steering committee
has worked very closely with us and
developing this retirement seminar
including all three sessions picking
speakers and so we really appreciate
their work let's see Robin DeAndre I
believe is here if you could stand that
would help me I guess so we have Robin
DeAndre and these names are listed on
your program and so he is a professor of
orthopedic surgery emeritus then we have
John booga who is also chair of our
executive committee of the emeritus
College not on the steering committee
toe and let's see who else we have Ron
Frank dean emeritus of the business
school and rod hunter who is professor
of pastoral theology emeritus so if you
have any questions specifically about
the retirement seminars please don't
hesitate to contact one of them or again
just come talk to me about it so right
now i'm going to introduce Joe and
Dalton who was also on our steering
committee and she is also remembered the
emeritus college and she is professor
emeritus of nursing and she'll introduce
our speaker Louis Richie
good afternoon and welcome to all of you
such a beautiful day I'm glad you
decided to come inside it was like such
a treat after all of the dreariness and
colas that we've had this afternoon it's
my pleasure to introduce our speaker dr.
Louis Ritchie I suspect that many of you
may know dr. Richard because she's had a
very active role in health care here in
the community and in the state educated
as a geriatric nurse practitioner an
adult educator dr. Ritchie has practiced
in the field of gerontology for over
three decades and my hats off to her
kudos to her for that very dedicated
service to a very needy profession and a
very needy group of individuals
currently she's employed by the
Institute of gerontology at the
University of Georgia although she
previously worked here at the emory
Center for Health and Ageing she held
that position until it closed for years
ago dr. Richie also worked with an NIH
ni a grant that focused on reducing
perhaps the most common problem in the
elderly and that is the problem of false
Falls are the reason that many of us
have moved all of the small rugs out of
our homes and that we carefully hold on
to sterile stair railings when we're
going up and down stairs because we
don't there is that fear and maybe dr.
Ritchie is even going to talk to us
about that as an expert in aging dr.
Richie comes to us today to share her
expertise regarding a topic very near
and dear to our hearts as an adult
educator she knows that it is the
teachable moment and she knows that we
as retired or soon to be retired
individuals our learners who know that
when the facts are relevant and we can
practice what we have learned we will do
well welcome to you and thanks for being
here doctor
it's something can all of you hear me if
I don't stand back there yeah good thank
you well I was asked to talk to you
about creative approaches to healthy
retirement and I have to tell all of you
that the first thing i did when i looked
at the series when charity sent me the
information and i looked at the the
content and I looked up creative that
was what boggled my mind how do I put
together something creative I know that
there are people here who have worked in
health care that there are people who
have worked in sciences and have worked
in a number of different areas and I was
thinking of how does one retire
creatively so when I looked it up i saw
that the cinnamons synonyms are at full
creative imaginative ingenious
innovative and inventive and I'm hoping
that one of those might fit the way you
have retired or are planning to retire
because I wasn't sure how to relate this
because every one of us knows that no
matter how well we prepare ourselves if
you've prepared yourself for aging you
don't know what's going to happen to you
regrettably something can always happen
when you least expect it we're going on
a cruise and you have a stroke or I am
going to be planning to move into a
different home and I fall and break my
leg and these are the things that are
going to happen health wise and I don't
want to paint a dreary picture because
I've got a very positive attitude about
aging I want you to know that and and I
know that one of the things that my
colleagues have worked with me on for
the last few years is you know Lois
sometimes you have to be realistic and
practical aging isn't always beautiful
ok and as long as we get past that and
we remain creative I think that you'll
understand what I'm going to try to talk
to you about and I hope that you'll
interrupt in this
be interactive and you'll just talk to
me whenever you have a thought or a
question okay and I may have to put my
glasses on because one of the things
that's happened in the last six months
is that my distance vision has minimized
a little bit more every time because you
know presbyopia happens but the
interesting thing about presbyopia as
I'll tell you afterward is that it
usually happens when your body so I've
had several years to adjust to this
changes in much of the changes in my
eyes and only now am i suffering from
presbyopia so we'll we'll go on I'll
talk to you a little bit about George
said this was going to work at the
computer okay okay maybe it went off
see you never know when something's
going to happen when you least expect it
thank you know it's going to work
alright you think ok so I looked for
some words that would be appropriate to
what we're talking about and this one
seemed pretty well appropriate to this
is that most adults spend a lot of years
looking forward to retirement however if
you have been studying the research and
you've been keeping up you know that a
lot of us are not looking forward to
retirement a lot of people today keep
thinking of that next job or what I can
do when I retire from my current job and
there isn't that same look at retirement
that there was even 20 years ago today
people are always looking for ways to
keep engaged and to stay involved so
whether you're still planning are you
ready to make the change there's a lot
you can do towards a healthy retirement
so I'm hoping that after we get through
talking today that you'll be able to
discuss the physiological changes that
are associated with normal aging that
we're going to describe the components
of a comprehensive geriatric assessment
and I put that in there because many of
you may know that under Medicare many
doctors offices now are requiring a very
very intensive questionnaire we asked
two people over 65 who qualify for
Medicare examinations explain the terms
health wellness chronic illness
geriatrics and gerontology and I put
those in there because I had the
occasion to take one of my clients to an
emergency room not too long ago and the
emergency room doctor medical doctor
asked me exactly what's the difference
between geriatrics and gerontology so I
thought I'd put that in there just for
us to have a review and then identify
steps to take for a good retirement and
probably any one of those steps may or
may not work for any one of you but
that's the important thing to know that
we're all different that we all started
out differently and we all going to end
up differently and you each have to
choose what it is that you want to do to
make your retirement a healthy happy one
I like that because we have this
wonderful act and a woodpecker just
nodding away holes throughout their
thing
you never know when something's going to
come along and mess up any plans that
you have so creative retirement I
mentioned that to you already I looked
at the three topics that you've been
offered and each one of them is very
important the psychology of creative
transitions to retirement when at the
Institute of gerontology I've had the
privilege of interviewing a few of the
centenarians they did the centenarians
study there for 20 years and I had the
opportunity to work and speak with
several centenarians and what always
amazed me each time I talked to one of
them is how different their approach to
their aging has been and I was talking
to people who are a hundred and six a
hundred and 110 I think the oldest one
at the time was a hundred and eleven
years old and when talking to these
people I realized that every one of them
had a different approach to the way they
lived and the way they retired and yet
they all lived past a hundred one man I
think you may have seen his picture in
the paper he was in the study in every
day of his life he had sausage and
biscuits for breakfast with gravy every
day of his life there goes the theory on
eating well okay so then the Appel the--
living I'm just going to tell you a
little bit about what I've learned and
what I'm sure a lot of you are learning
about how we age normally and some of
the things that may interfere with how
we age and then next time you're going
to be hearing about the financial
planning for Creative retirement and
probably all pulled together that
financial component is a very important
one so I'm glad that that's being
included because that is that is so
important in many areas not just the
money in the dollars health it's a state
of complete physical mental and social
well-being medical professionals were
called homeostasis when you're in good
homeostasis everything's working well
wellness
wellness is an important distinction
from health because it's an active
process of becoming aware of and making
choices towards a more successful
existence and and the process means that
improvement is always possible and when
you are well you may have an illness but
if you have your positive attitude and
you're treating it well then you are
moving towards that progress chronic
illness it's an illness or disorder that
is prolonged course doesn't resolve
spontaneously and is rarely completely
cured geriatrics is the field of
medicine developed to maintain and
improve a patient's current level of
function in addition to caring for
complex medical illnesses and there is
an outstanding geriatric center right
down the road here and i spent seven
years at it so it's Wesley woods as an
outstanding geriatric facility
gerontology is the study of all aspects
of the aging process and there's the big
difference and i'll show you how i
illustrated it including the clinton
clinical psychologic economic and
sociological issues encountered by older
persons does that sound pretty much like
what you wanted to hear about today good
okay so I i found an umbrella because
you know when anything's under an
umbrella it could be a lot of different
things that we put under the umbrella of
so i decided to use an umbrella as my
gerontology illustration and underneath
that looking at the different aspects of
it i saw that the handle of the umbrella
is the geriatrics component because if
you don't have I don't think that they
we have a if you don't have the health
then all of these these other things on
what you have to work on with the help
you have to be how work on your health
so the geriatrics is very important it's
that handle that holds up everything in
gerontology and then the psychology and
you have the emotional aspect I don't
know how many of you are retired or how
many
planning to retire but for many people
their work has become them and if that
is what you are is what you've done and
your identity is what you've done for
many people it's very difficult to make
that transition and say I'm not going to
work anymore I'm going to become the
person that I thought I'd like to be or
I'd like to do something different from
what i have been doing well I was going
to use it but I can well thank you thank
you so that's in addition to this okay
now this is where I'm going to have
problems okay so you've got the
psychology in the emotional aspects the
family dynamics for any of you who are
dealing with family that is becoming a
major issue in gerontology family
dynamics the caregiver when did my
children begin to think that I wasn't
capable of taking care of myself and
when did I start getting calls from my
children my adult children saying to me
are you okay is everything all right do
you think you should be doing that do
you want me to do it for you so we're
seeing a change in the family dynamics
or the visibility of the family dynamics
and a lot of people are having a
difficult time dealing with that because
they want to grow old and they want to
be able to be independent but families
don't want us to be and I'm not even
going to spend spend a lot of time
talking to you today about taking the
car away because that is a serious issue
very serious issue the end of life
issues I won't embarrass anybody who
hasn't but I'm hoping that everyone of
you has done advanced directives I'm
hoping everyone of you has your
end-of-life issues prepared for and
taken care of and more than that that
you have given them to somebody or that
somebody to whom you've given the
responsibility knows that they've been
given it because that's what happens a
lot of times we put in the child and
that child says to you I don't want
know anything about it no because you're
going to live forever and they don't
want to know about your advanced
directives and somehow you've got to
make them aware of their
responsibilities to know where they are
and what they are and what they should
be doing and any other legal issues you
can have a fiduciary power of attorney
you can have a health care power of
attorney you can have one in the same
but you've got to make that decision but
also you have to be aware of the fact
that under the state laws that a person
who is your power of attorney has to
have it in writing that they can have
access to all of your information and
there are papers now that that will give
you information on what you're supposed
to be doing and the last one is the care
consideration and we have 41 million
caregivers in this country now people
who are caring for older adults caring
for their family members and without a
lot of background and an understanding
of what it is they're supposed to be
doing the social aspects I think a very
important the social aspects are the
family the maintaining of close
relationship with the family the
spiritual your church your temple your
religious affiliations activities
staying involved and engaged in some
type of activity it's very good mentally
it's very good socially and it's very
good intellectually it has all of these
positives and general engagement being
engaged reading the paper watching the
news interacting with people having an
opinion talking about the opinions that
you have the finances very important
finances are your living expenses I met
with a friend today who was going to do
a pass with me she's going to be
retiring in june and what she said to me
was I've got to stop thinking about how
I'm going to live on my income without
my my paycheck counts little bit silly
doesn't it have any of you had to deal
with that all of a sudden you realize
those extra few dollars that you were
made
I'm not coming in anymore and you have
to alter the way you're going to be
living just so you understand from a
health perspective these are all very
important factors because your health
and your emotions all interact in a lot
of people who have a lot of stress find
that they are not healthy so when we
talk about all of these things there's
everything that you should be aware of
and you should be planning for your
medical expenses we see a lot of changes
happening with insurance policies with
insurance companies with your payment's
you should be aware of them and your
housing am I going to have to move am I
going to have to make alterations to my
home what's the cost going to be should
I have put in grab bars in late the
bathrooms should I make sure that I have
a different type of flooring because I
might fall should I be aware of the way
my cabinets are in the kitchen what
about my lighting am I going to have to
have an electrician in and do something
different with my lighting because my
eyes on as good as they were and there's
a lot of glare and as you've already
heard Falls are a serious problem
so just a little bit of updating for you
cuz I'm sure that these are numbers that
you're all aware of that the United
States population 65 and above we have
about 40 1 million people who are above
65 4.6 million or 85 and above and
seventy two thousand plus or minus are a
hundred and older in this country we
have a lot of older people the greatest
thing about getting older is that you
don't lose the other ages you've been
and a lot of us spend a lot of time
telling people about all those other
things we've been and done don't we okay
78 million baby boomers are going to
begin to turn 65 in 2011 the aging of
Georgia's population is one of the most
significant trends affecting the state
the aging population in Georgia is going
to increase 143 percent by 2030 in 2011
the first of the baby boomers was born
and there's been some question are there
any sociologists here you know that that
there has been a lot of discussion by
sociologists about the actual baby
boomer is when did we expand from the
Korean War to nineteen sixty-four
because originally the baby boomer
generation extended from 1946 to 1955 in
somewhere I don't know whether it was
financial whether it was a slip of the
tongue and somebody didn't want to
correct somebody so that they changed it
but we know now that that we're talking
about people who parents and children
are both baby boomers and generationally
and thought process when we're different
in the way we think so if you were born
in 1946 and you had a child born in 1964
conceivably you could be both the baby
boomers or you are both baby boomers so
there is a lot of question about that
but for the sake of what they're saying
now we'll use these figures
and they're going to be celebrating 65
and George's populations 60 and older
increased this was an interesting piece
of data this all came from the Atlanta
Regional Commission Bureau of Statistics
81.6 percent from 1990 through 2010 so
we're a Beijing state let's see the
fastest growing age group is 85 and
they're 264 point nine percent increase
was at the end of 2010 a lot of old
people okay just very briefly because I
didn't even know some of these counties
and perhaps some of you don't know them
but the top ten counties with the
largest growth population 65 to 69
through 2010 Henry Cherokee paulding
winnett Fayette Lee is it's shyly sky
Lee Dawson in Bryan and the largest
growth population 85 and older is in
dawson Chattahoochee paulding Henry
white that banks Forsyth Cherokee
Pickens and catoosa so they've spread
out they're moving out all over older
adults have more unique challenges
they're different medical needs but the
process of aging is normal and I often
tell the students we have a graduate
class in geriatrics issues and aging and
one of the things that that we look at
often is why is it that we look at each
age group as a very positive in their
aging process we look at the infant that
baby I can't believe I just saw that
baby a month ago and look at how it's
grown and then we see that baby and it
becomes a little toddler and then their
toddler becomes a kidney garner and that
kindergartener becomes a an 8th grader
and that eighth grader becomes a high
school student and we enjoy watching
this growth and development and then
they become high school graduates and
then they become college graduates and
then lo and behold many of you have seen
your children have children of their own
and you can't believe what happened to
all the years
and then they continue on and maybe get
they get older but we're getting older
too so we're having a difficult time
putting together the fact that our
children are getting older as we're
getting older and then 65 comes that
magic number and all of a sudden you've
become old you no longer are just moving
through life's process which took you
from infancy through to 65 you are now
old however the World Health
Organization you probably all notice
that the World Health Organization
dictates that 85 is old in this country
we're aging and when you get old you're
about 85 and that when I talk to you
about these physiological changes we're
looking at an 80 year old now for the
most part however I regret to say there
are people who ask 55 who are old I have
a good friend who is a delightful person
but i honestly believe although i didn't
know her when she was 21 that she was
probably old when she was 21 have you
ever known people like that they just
they they act old their their general
demeanor is old they don't have a lot of
of life in them but they're nice people
they're wonderful people okay so getting
old doesn't mean getting sick okay aging
is not a disease but we know it isn't
all sunshine and roses I mean that's the
fact of life things are going to happen
you survived adolescence in puberty you
enjoy 30 or 40 years of effortless
health K&I i heard that and there was a
professor emeritus of orthopedics here
probably certainly can speak for an hour
on what happens to the aging bones in
our bodies and why we fall and why all
these things happen to us but then
things start to change age is remodeling
everything from your bones to your brain
cells and you can't take it sitting down
you just have to keep moving and you
have to keep adapting and you have to be
creative and change the age-related body
changes that all of us are seeing or
have seen a decrease in height this is
we're based on 80 years
78 80 but keep in mind that some people
are not going to have this because we
now have a generation that exercises a
lot more so we're going to see some
changes in the next decade of the aging
body even more excuse me more than we've
seen now so you've got there is a
decrease in height because you've got
the vertebral column and you have these
pads and these pads start to dry a
little bit and as they dry they compress
and as they compress fractions of inches
diminished from your height so that's
very likely to happen and many people
will say I'm two inches shorter than I
was when I was 50 decrease in weight and
I'm waiting for that patiently because i
was told that i'm going to lose some
weight when i get older so we do have a
decrease in weight and a lot of it is
because of eating and just because of
body mass the decreased lean fat body
composition is that lean layer of fat
that all of us have that keeps us
insulated and as that thins out as we
get older you'll probably notice that
the old people that you know walk around
with sweaters in July and they're always
cold it's because they don't have that
layer of fine tissue that keeps them
insulated the high-frequency hearing we
don't hear as well everybody and
everybody doesn't lose their hearing as
they get older contrary to what we'd
like to think that they get deaf when
they get old we don't but some people
will and the most common loss is the
loss of the sounds of the bowels so that
you won't be able to hear the BCD you'll
hear the AE I oh and you but you can't
hear the BCD V and if you call up your
friend and say were you planning to go
that at that show at the church tonight
what might come out is we're getting on
her and hind because they don't hear it
and if you don't have respect for that
many times what we do is begin to think
hmm they're losing it then
not understanding me they're losing it
we immediately move over to that mental
state because of that cognitive state
because after all what happens when you
get old you lose your cognitive
abilities I'm not saying that seriously
I don't want that to be recorded as an
absolute the visual acuity yes am I did
you did yes fine no problem at all was
able to hear very well couldn't walk
without a walker and was a very
arthritic had severe arthritis in both
his hands and in his feet his cognitive
status was remarkable remarkable any
other questions okay be as i said the
visual acuity about 40 you begin to
notice some changes you have to hold the
paper in a different place you have to
have glasses so we can't blame matt on
aging the things that we can blame on
aging are those that are truly
presbyopic the presbyopia will produce
cataracts glaucoma macular degeneration
and changes in the lens that will
promote all of those other problems but
all of us well with few exceptions will
have changes by the time we're 40
slowing of the GI motility and there's a
lot of study on that a lot of people are
wondering why does this happen and it is
not always indicative of aging there are
very a lot of young people now who have
problems with their gastrointestinal
system that's why we have all of these
commercials on television about every
kind of product that you could find for
your
of laxatives to keep you going to keep
you settled to keep you you know what
they all are about their lot of them on
the television now a lot of people will
develop constipation they don't eat
properly they don't have enough fiber
they don't drink enough fluids decrease
in hours of sleep sometimes the research
will show that loss of sleep is really
not what the problem is it's when people
are sleeping a lot of older people will
not off frequently they'll sit down
because they have the time and their
their life patterns have changed and
they're no longer on a job in on a
schedule so they'll sit down and they'll
nod off and then they wonder why they're
not sleeping at night it's because
they've already slept three hours during
the day very often but there are sleep
problems there's sleep apnea there are a
number of things that I'll go over
afterward in the REM sleep which is so
important because that the period of
time when your eye the movement is so
important to all of us and that's when
you have those brief dreams and you need
that so a lot of people do have problems
the slowed response time yes there is
some slowness in responding in some
cases but if you know about it and you
work on it and you're aware of it you
can promote it promote better health and
better response time for long a period
of time got what I was going to say they
are okay not to mention the aches and
pains because as we get older a lot of
people have some aches and pains a lot
of people are going to develop chronic
illnesses arthritis hypothyroidism these
things are going to happen to people and
the family dynamics are going to cause a
lot of angst and a lot of stress in
people's lives life changes a lot of
people do not adapt well to life changes
I do a series of programs at pack
springs which is a continuing care
and community beautiful place it's a
place where anybody would want to live
if they were moving out of their own
facility of their own homes absolutely
beautiful and yet I have spoken with
more people there who wish they'd never
moved who wish they'd kept their own
home you don't know what's going to
happen until it happens no I don't know
about all of you but I hadn't learned
about Maslow's theory a long time ago
and one day I decided that I'm going to
incorporate it into my talks on aging
because why else 40 years ago I learned
all of this in college so I might as
well use it and refresh your memories on
the Maslow's theory and I adapted it to
aging so bear with me and those of you
who have taught Maslow's theory or know
of Maslow's theory you'll see what I
mean I learned a lot when I graduated
from college I don't know how many of
you thought self-actualization was
existential was it was just when if you
were self actualized you were really
something superb that's pretty much what
my professor led me to believe that
that's what Maslow believed okay i
changed it just a little bit okay so
what I looked at is is what he did was
focus on the potential in the fully I
have to move over because I can't see
fully functioning person the lower the
needs the more fundamental the want that
sound like what you learned okay so if
you're a sick person what do you want
you just want to get better Maslow's
theory is basic needs have to be met
this is Lois's interpretation basic
needs physiological needs yeah we want
to have a toilet close by when we need
it we'd like to know that there's food
available if we want to eat and they
basic physiological needs safety needs I
want to know that when I walk from here
to my car that nobody is going to try to
steal anything from me I want to know
that in my home I have safety that I'm
going to be all right needs of love
of affection and belonging this is a big
topic because in my generation that as a
child of the 50s we didn't even talk
about it and your parents you you had no
idea how anything happened because it
never happened with your parents and all
of a sudden now we're talking about
sexuality and sex and about being older
and having a relationship and things are
changing a lot and it's based on a need
of love and affection end of belonging
we all want to have somebody that we
belong to a need for self esteem
everybody would like to feel that they
are important and that they have some
worth all of you who have retired when
you talk to anybody do you tell people
what you're doing now and you tell
people what you did we become attached
to what we did a need for self-esteem
and I need for self-actualization and
that was the one I had the most
difficult time with how does one
interpret self-actualization so I looked
at our perceived needs and this is what
our children usually see need to be
cared for yes
while Maslow's hierarchy is that there
are certain needs that have to be met in
everybody's life we have any that was
that was well I I would probably have to
spend a long time discussing it with you
but basically I just put it together
with how we get older and Maslow's
theory is that that there are needs that
each of us has each one of us has needs
thank you for helping you know attorney
I had to stop and think about it because
they we have we all have basic needs and
and each one is constructed on the one
the previous one we have certain things
and the self-actualization that he
talked about and and again I used the
word theory because when I was learning
this in college many years ago and as
I've looked at the revisiting the theory
in its called Maslow's theory of
hierarchy why I use the word theory
because I'm just using and I explained
that to you yes you might help
miss hybrid never was very precise about
the higher even the basic need all that
ranked priority exactly us unneeded came
ahead of rubbish and when you get to
self-actualization understand that meant
moving from having to have certain
things to have it to me be certain
things exactly about being motivation
and it becomes more self expressive and
more a matter of affirming something
about yourself in the world rather than
just acquiring surprise
thank you when you thought you couldn't
get there and once you have the basics
government that's kind of versatile it's
imperative it is and I I put this in not
so much to discuss that his theory but
to help it was more of a you know what
you could take anything and put it any
place and make it work if you want to
and that was how I use this with no
intent to clearly define why he used
this fear of the word theory did the
height of self-actualization I was just
trying to construct a way to look at us
in our aging and self-actualization my
interpretation of it based on what my
college professors told me many years
ago was that very few people would ever
reach that level of self-actualization
did anybody else graduate from college
in the 60s and learn that that that
that's what we learned is and and I did
not mean to put this in as a lesson in
the psychology of Maslow's theory of
hierarchy I simply was just trying to
point out that as we get old and we all
have needs that have to be met and I
would be very happy to spend a long time
going over why I did this but basically
all I wanted to do is show you that we
have basic physiological needs that have
to be met in their order of hierarchy we
have safety needs that have to be met
and everybody thinks about some time
when you were walking some place or
doing something and you heard a sound
and your body just stopped activity and
you were sure that someone was either
coming up behind you or something was
happening to you going to happen to you
and then that sound went away and all of
a sudden your body relaxed and that
stress impulse relaxed and if those
things happen often enough they are
going to cause you health problems so
that was another thing that we dubbed
off into when we looked at the safety
factors how they can cause stress in
your minds if you live in an area that's
not safe and you're always afraid that
someone's going to break into your home
you live in that chronic stress state
and depending on what part of your body
is affected by that means so da talked
about that many years ago it's been over
the years we've heard how stress affects
your body and now we're recognizing that
as we get older a lot of older people
suffer the effects of stress on their
bodies so I thought safety needs is a
very important component the need for
love and affection and belonging I do
believe from talking to many people that
they don't think that older people are
sexual or that have any feelings are
caring not true need for self-esteem you
answered the question I asked how many
of you when you're introduced to
somebody tell them what you did rather
than what you're doing because we need
that esteem and as we get older we still
want people to think that we are
somebody and for some people what they
were is what is tied into who they are
now not the fact that I'm a grandma and
I'm just loving it oh no I'm a former
professor in this school and this is
what I did okay so we look at that is
that that need for a steam the
self-actualization I think I said it
when I introduced this is that when I
was learning self-actualization I
thought that you arrived at some very
godly like place
a change in what you just described that
people should start to change their view
of what selfless to do the most stupid
that you should be happy to tell people
I'm the grand father of three beautiful
I don't advocate anything I'm a nurse
only if it's healthy in your mind and to
give me I don't want to be flip about it
but if it if you're if you're very
comfortable being in that role I'm not
going to say to you oh no you've got to
forget that person you were you've got
to be who you are now that's not what
what my role is my role is the health
aspects and if you're comfortable with
that role I think that that's fine and
and I hope that that's what I told you
at the beginning is that I can only give
you my thoughts on this and and working
with people who have retired because my
population is mostly an older population
I I would have to say that there are
many people whose identity is linked to
who they were rather than who they are
and if that's good for them that's fine
but if you go home at night and you have
angst because you're no longer who you
were and who you told somebody you were
then you have to you're the one that has
to deal with it does that sound too far
off and you understand what I'm trying
to say is I don't know how to explain a
lot of the things I can only point them
out you're the one that has to explain
them to yourself we each have to be able
to describe what what we are to
ourselves first of all when you asked
about self-actualization if you have had
a good this is my interpretation because
the self-actualization I was taught is
that very few people ever our self
actualized my interpretation of
self-actualization is if you can sit
back as a retired person and reflect on
your
life and be grateful for all that you
have had in your life and look forward
to the changes and the creative ways
you're going to live the rest of your
life then you are self actualized a
person who is happy with themselves help
me out there sounds like you have some
ideas on self-actualization and that was
the way I wanted it to be interpreted
for the purpose of this not that I
wanted to make it a sociological no
discussion or debate I really just felt
that this describes what happens to us
as we get older and because I never knew
what to do with Maslow's theory I put it
in here
I think if you have other friends and
people you know who have had those
experiences then you're prepared for
what is going to come and what I've
learned is that women talk to each other
a whole lot more about these things than
men do and I know that helped me quite a
bit and sometimes these they're very
temporary those kinds of self-esteem
issues it's home Ed's question about
self-actualization and it was a very
very general way of looking at it and
I'm sure that perhaps in the future you
can have different workshops that
address different theories that have
peplau the importance of hierarchy your
list is in what regard is the hierarchy
of importance they start out this
logically are from safety needs from the
development stroke needs of esteem and
finally be able hose you go
because it should have been the training
in math words exactly as a triangle
upside down I just found one from the
bottom up is a physiological needs
because he loved me I I apologize
that'll change that and I'll make it you
two okay a triangle the first thing is a
physiological needs and based on that
would say then above that the safety of
that perfection that's okay back in my
mind I defer or lease a lower basic is
about I shouldn't effective thank you
for the challenge I'll kingdom okay the
perceived needs as I started to tell you
is the needs to be cared for okay that's
what we perceive old people need to be
cared for we perceived that they need to
be advised that they're incapable making
decisions on their own and that they
have to be advised we perceive that they
need to be managed that all of their
activities and decisions have to be
managed and that they need to be
controlled and I'm going to be
responsible for everything in your life
because you're not capable of doing it
anymore these are the perceived needs of
many people that's the family dynamics
that is what happens with family
dynamics is that the children begin to
think that this is what their parents
need and they don't need that naturally
needs of us as we get older to be
respected to be acknowledged to be
listened to and to be admired and the
issues of every age is to have their
physiological needs Matt to be safe and
secure to be loved and
belong to have a sense a feeling of self
esteem and to be self actualized to be
where you want to be that that's what
what the end of this is and that's what
I had hoped that I would present to you
so back to normal aging probably and
lodged in a book a couple of years ago
called young the next year and their
theory and then what they decided is
that you should exercise you should quit
eating junk food you should deal with
your emotions your attitudes and you
should learn to care very simple that's
that's normal aging this came from a man
in a nursing home one of our old people
James big the season was 104 years old
he's no longer living but his only
advice is to lay off Alcohol Tobacco and
while and then the prevention they're
going to go through these but this is
the health things that you should all be
inspected you have when you're looking
at types of prevention and Prevention's
becoming a keyword in the health care
reform issues primary is prevent any
disease state from occurring the
exercise programs to prevent oez
secondary disease risk factors exist
reduce the likelihood of your disease
okay here you come from a family where
there's a high incidence of patio master
reasons to reduce the cholesterol to
prevent the hottest and the tertiary the
diseases exist reduced the long-term
complications person has had a heart
attack and they have to take steps to
prevent problems from occurring and
they're going to do a progressive of
rehabilitation program screenings
everybody should have screenings
regularly the problems that you're going
to face as you get older with healthcare
fears are you going to be able to get
the screenings that you need and these
are things that you're going to have to
be prepared to discuss with your
healthcare provider your doctors are
probably going to do whatever they can
to give you the treatments and the
diagnostic tests that you have to have
but you may come under a problem where
your insurance company won't pay means
the decisions that you have to make and
these are becoming scenes it's a lot of
older people the use of the tests of
techniques to determine risk factor
profile and likelihood of disease it can
be a simple survey and blood tests but
for a pap smear or more aggressive exams
or the pet scheme PET scan is a very
expensive test and it is not often done
but if other tests are not finding a
problem and the symptoms continue to
occur it may be advised what does that
why does the doctor asked these are just
things that all of us being lost at any
time the chest pain shortness of breath
palpitations act as nice silent hat
attacks and regular hydrates anieron
high thyroid function and they ask you
these questions so that they can't make
a decision as to what type of test to
use and what should be done for you
nausea stomach pain vomiting diarrhea
medication side effects
patient colon a GI cancer an ulcer
disease all have to be checked on
trouble sleeping retiring this could be
depression serious problem that this is
a bit older low thyroid function sleep
apnea in half day why all the lab work
because these simple tests when a doctor
looks at these tests they can determine
a lot just by looking after the CBC the
complete bug found could identify things
such as the new bikini infection a
fasting lipid panel can be total
cholesterol and the camp for the CP
compound is a kidney and liver function
very important sometimes asymptomatic
unless they look at these blood tests
the cancer screening measures I've have
a colon cancer for prostate or breast
and for cervical and as you get older
you should continue to have these tests
and just because you turn to a certain
age doesn't mean that you no longer have
to happen yes not it was understanding
going up for on the latest physical that
the doctor said that over the age of 65
they weren't recommending pap smears
anymore yes they they don't always
recommend
generalizations are good okay sexual
activity has to be considered multiple
sex partners definitely have pap smear
regularly every every woman should have
a pap smear at least every couple of
years they have a single pattern it's
it's recommended even uh or over 65 to
80 up to 80 and now 80 might be changed
very soon awesome tonight yeah in her
under the cancer screening measures the
lung cancer there's no data to support
annual chest x-rays ovarian cancer no
gave the support of dog alpha sound of
blood tests skin cancers recommended
recommendation is to have one completed
skin exam but there's no data to support
it anytime you see something change in
shipbuilding den college soccer field
hands are possible endoscopy patients
with long-standing reflux disease this
has become important because more and
more people are suffering from reflux
and was hearing a lot more spoken about
reflux disease after Z's number one
killer of both women and the
manifestations of coronary syndrome a
heart attack ischemic heart disease
heart failure hypertensive heart disease
and valvular heart disease Lindy Bell
quite a lot more is being said about
this now they're finding in a lot more
with the more more invasive testing the
video after I this the second most
common complaint in the doctor's office
for persons over 55 high blood pressure
is still number one and there are
different types of arthritis and they
are treated differently osteoarthritis
most people will develop some form of
osteoarthritis before they that caused
by default ramen joints occurs with age
profession and obesity paying the
morning with stiffness that's better
with repeated movement and half hour but
the pain may get worse with use then the
treatment of choice is exercised first
on medication is a set of mannequins the
tylenol products osteoporosis is a major
risk factor fractures of the hip and
spine any factors can occur with minor
injury in patients with more severe
osteoporosis more women develop it than
men many men who have drunk a lot of
alcohol I don't want to say alcoholics
but who have enjoyed multiple drinks on
a daily basis more likely to develop
osteoporosis diagnosis is x-ray or
dexa the treatments calcium vitamin D
vitamin D is a foundation something else
that's being discussed about their bio
phosphonates Fosamax actonel calcitonin
malkinson nasal spray a lot of people
taking mr. sprays for osteoporosis and
the hormone replacement therapy which is
very time to mention the rheumatoid
arthritis usually morning stiffness at
last longer remain hours joints are
swollen and constant virus and we have
associated fatigue and fever specific
blood tests are available but the
diagnosis is based on physical
historically animals and the treatments
I'm nonsteroidal corticosteroids in
hypothyroid the women's health studies
of the nineties were the first to
disclose to health profession that a lot
of women postmenopausal II have lowered
i will type mo a thyroid levels
disorder symptoms include fatigue
depression making the crews cold
tolerance hair loss dry skin and
swelling of the legs the problem is many
doctors do not do a thyroid testing a
lot of women have symptoms then not
being treated because they don't have
the tested treatments with thyroid
hormone replacement then sent through an
inning is a very easy test to do the
sweet vacuum has been identified as a
cause of heart disease and high blood
pressure they can stop breathing for
small periods of time in your sleep
after news when they have damage to the
lungs and over time diagnosis is by
comics are not
sleep studies and like down the road
here dammit excellence sleep study
clinic thinking this positive airway
pressure applied nexus if have many of
you may know people who are on CPAP or
you may take in Sipan urinary
incontinence is a serious problem as we
get older more so because nobody talks
about it then because of the treatment
is that normal in any age it is not a
normal part of Aging you have urge
incontinence whether you urinate you
followed by incontinence old flow build
up the urine and eventually of filling
the bladder stress incontinence you
cough or sneeze and you dribble and
functional mobility issues preventing is
evolving and that's mostly the people
cannot walk cannot move quickly and went
to the bathroom when they feel the urge
and because you're dealing with the
generation that didn't get to talk about
their bowel or bladder habits they don't
discuss it so they don't tell somebody
who really have to go to the bathroom
and then sit there and squeeze and
squeeze and hold it as long as they can
and then they get up in it just pulls up
and that's a lot as we you see the
younger generation they are much more
open about discussing they handle the
bathroom whereas years and years ago
perhaps many of you remembered older
people would never discuss having to go
to the bathroom it's very private so you
have to keep that in mind that that's a
generation you're discussing the
impotence male erectile dysfunction I
can talk about this because it's on
television every single day really in
this the saddest thing to me is a good
that the models that they have on are
all probably 40 year old male erectile
dysfunction is a lot of causes had in
the arteries the after at Rose closest
diabetes high blood pressure and
medications there was a study done in
psychology today that showed that many
younger men who are on cholesterol
medications were finding that they were
having erectile dysfunction so they were
going on the viagra and other
medications and having all kinds of
health issues so one thing sometimes
doesn't work well for something else
medications a viagra levitra use the
medicated beautiful system surgery in
document sister
no sir lowering cholesterol
Communications have been found to cause
some problems with women's and so
younger younger men had taken I was
going to put on here and I'd left it off
and then showed someone getting their
prescriptions and right next to what
there was a little sign and a little
book that said side effects from your
medications and and that's one of the
things that we really don't talk about a
lot and people don't understand that
many of us as we get older I'm not going
to react the same two medications as we
did when you remember that your body
it's a process process called
pharmacokinetics and it's the process
with which the medication is taken into
the body how it's used and how is it's
excreted and different people depending
on the medicines there on the inactivity
their general health status are going to
react and respond differently to
medications that's why it's so important
for you to be a very active involved
consumer and left your health care
providing know when you're having any
problems this was just a tattoo
and this is a big problem too because
many women are very dimension I just
mentioned this very grateful because we
know that a lot of people are caught up
in their concerns are getting older and
they're losing their mind losing their
capability memory impairments that are
normal with aging not forgetting me you
put things you've got to keep in mind
that you have a brain that has a lot in
it you've accumulated 60 70 80 years
information that's in there praying some
place you have that the campus and you
have all these different areas in your
brain for those of you will remember
your biology and you're going to have a
lot of information and sometimes it's
going to take a few seconds for you we
call it to get it back again so you may
forget when you put something you may
forget people's names and they remember
them you may miss words in normal
conversation that could be combination
of hearing and of just not remembering
concentrating or something else that
somebody was saying my colleague from
your Center for Health and Ageing here
than I would talk to me something about
a person have worked in the apartment
and she was the business office manager
for the division of geriatrics and we
sat for 10 minutes thinking what was her
name we could not remember her name and
Johanna said to me whenever you think
about it call me up and I said even if
it's three in the morning she does call
me because I'll probably be awake
wondering what her name was and in about
ten o'clock at night I picked up the
phone I called her
Becky it's all me are Becky and I hung
up the phone but neither one of us could
remove me I'm sure every one of you has
done something like that that does not
mean that you you're cognitively
impaired they've got a lot of things
going on in that brain memory and
cameras that are abnormal with aging
behavioral changes doing things that you
never did before frequently getting lost
not recognizing people that you see
every day declaring instrumental
activities checkbox bill is shopping can
do to problems India thought process in
your thinking medications could cause a
lot of problems to any potential side
effects dimension most medicines are
safe effectively and minimal side
effects and you discuss the side effects
with your doctor and you find that they
are causing you a lot of problems do you
make up a recommendation for another
medication creative approach the age
retired for that there evidence that the
particularly
the appropriate urdu proximate cause
like we have here they're absolutely
best keep your mind active keep your
mental mental brain going constantly
interact with people socialize keep up
with activities this is what the
literature says and regrettably as I say
this you're all going to say him I know
somebody who did all of that they were
fine right up until they were 18 years
old then they began losing it there's
always going to be that situation is
going to occur there are always going to
be those things that I'm not going to be
the way we can clean for them to be I
think that if i recall correctly there
was a professor here on the emory campus
who was the outstanding speaker
knowledgeable man able to interact in
many different areas and then who began
displaying some symptoms of strange
behaviors and ultimately was diagnosed
with Alzheimer's disease so I certainly
am NOT a an expert on how to prevent
everything from happening as we get
older to make it perfect I'm only
telling you that
the things that have been identified for
us to be aware on if you want your
retirement to be a healthy one and
keeping in mind that health may not be
optimal but wellness maybe because if
you've got a good attitude even if you
have a health issue it can be treated in
it can be monitored side effects are
difference than allergies nausea with
antibiotics is a side effect rash with
as well as an allergy can you
distinguish the difference vitamins are
herbals work this is a big thing for
older people I cannot tell you the
number of older people who are
supplementing their medications with
over-the-counter thermals and other
products and what they use there's no
data that exists that proves that
vitamin C at the union hall Arjun Singh
work different impact disease there is
some evidence that taking a vitamin C
regularly during the winter months or if
you're going to be flying might help you
to improve your immune system vitamin D
is now shown to aim in fall prevention
but the jury is out on all of these
other things that it's supposed to be
doing but it is recommended that
everybody over the age of 65 have a
baseline by the mendiny tests and blood
tests because there is evidence that
there may need some cognitive changes
and people who have very low vitamin D
and I'm promising everything with me yes
when you say to aid in fall prevention
so that would not necessarily mean
vitamin D would make your phone stronger
but maybe make you less clumsy and so
you fold it likely to fall or both okay
because of the calcining and the vitamin
D they that you have to have the vitamin
D with the calcium
to help the phosphate in the bones and
there is evidence that by taking a
vitamin D you enhance the effect of the
phosphate and it reduces the my mind
just dueling know when your bones the
density bone density is often affected
by Ebola indeed so it is said that if
you take a vitamin D tab or a few times
a week then you're going to enhance the
activity of the phosphate and that's
going to keep clean bone density from
from blowing this all of this make sense
to you is this is something that will
help you at least don't understand a
little bit about what your what we are
faced with with our are raging there's
some data that indicates all our mental
works or not prostate symptoms should
not be taken by anybody who has had
prostate cancer treatment st. John's
wort work similar fashion antidepressant
depression is a terrible problem and
most older people talking about older
people are talking about 65 70 75 80
year olds they don't want to talk about
depression because that's mental illness
and people
illness really bad shape and we don't
want anybody to know that it was mental
illness in our family so we don't talk
about depression and yet it is one of
the most serious problems we think we
see face engaging people and st. John's
what does work for some people whether
it's mental whether it's actual physical
I don't know but it does work there is
data the chosen through pulse mean
chondroitin can help restore cartilage I
think it can but then that's my opinion
and my personal experience with it so I
would say definitely that I have a very
bad right knee can address copy and I've
been taking glucosamine chondroitin for
several years in and I think it's works
back to maybe mind over matter you know
what's good for us and one's not good
for us of nature's who normally rather
eat what tastes with emphasis should be
on moderation and that was in the paper
again today I believe that watching what
you eat less food is what you should be
doing with permission to sometimes have
something bad for this comes from Tufts
University that's what the Maslow's
theory should become too
a pair of small amounts of fat on the
top and most of your intake should be
have for hundreds you're not the simple
ones the complex carbohydrates exercise
and research shows that sedentary non
active lifestyles increased disease when
the research shows the regular exercises
reduces disease rates so even if you
walk a lot you're doing exercise if you
can't get out and walk a lot sit in your
chair when you're watching television
and raise your legs and arms keep
containers but do something what could
your busy schedule better exercising how
are they are being dead 24 just going
back to that triangle you're saying that
you know the the most important thing
would be carbohydrates as opposed to
vegetables and fruits no I would say the
most importantly I said the most your
intake should be large amounts of
carbohydrates that's at the bottom not
that they're the most important you know
differently fruits and vegetables in
there has already been significant
evidence showing that fruits and
vegetables are very important in your
diet no I'm sorry if I know I just kind
of surprised that carbohydrates
represent such a larger but it's complex
and that's where people make a lot of
mistakes they think eating a slice of
bread butter is ok for them and they
don't realize that
the white bread does not have a lot of
nutritional value if you love Wonder
Bread because you like all those circles
a little fellow that's it does not is
not as nutritious as a good home Wayne
multigrain bread with a lot of five
minutes hey I could go on longer but I
really better get going is I'm just
about out of time okay how much is
enough you don't even gym membership you
can walk using say is that in the
housework pack away from the entrance to
the shopping center and walk your
vaccinations everybody should have the
influenza shot the flu shot everybody
should have an all new shop every 7 to
10 years very important the tetanus
vaccine every 10 years especially for
taking up woodworking or out gardening
something make sure you get a tetanus
vaccine hepatitis B vaccine there are
any guidelines for over 65 but a lot of
people do volunteer work in healthcare
facilities and it might be a good idea
for you to ask the people who are
responsible for that whether or not you
should have the shingles vaccine the
herpes zoster its new on the market and
I would urge everyone over 6
you have herpes the shingles vaccine
every one of you should happen and its
founder to Debbie stereotypes that old
people are not fail you're not demented
they're not lumpy and you're not setting
their wings although there are some
point this was from a British magazine
and it's important to have a twin for a
new wrinkle when you picture retirement
what do you say see new projects is sooo
completing all projects relaxation
travel time with grandkids today the
fact is that individuals are healthier
living honourable filling lines much
different from other generations many
many years ago when I became a nurse
practitioner I spent a lot of time at
Duke University at the gerontology
center and the director was people
buzzing and in one of his early lectures
when I was first they have to study
gerontology he said everybody thinking
or retirement or as they get older
should have three different planes using
three different capabilities because you
may be planning to do one thing and as I
said early when I started out you have a
stroke and you no longer able to do that
which you plan on doing you may become
blind and you all you did was looking
forward to is reading you may have to
think of something else always be
thinking of what you can do instead of
not always mean
because that's what too many of us do we
mean I on the excuse for why we can't do
something rather than thinking of
something else we can do he's a wise man
does not greed for the things which he's
not but rejoices for those which he has
only things that I can't explain you
know 2001 I money piece of Social
Security and a surge of the need cost
seems right that more and more persons
in characterizing what every time and
signifies and it's a given that to grow
old gracefully must remain energetic in
old age in contact with I was unoccupied
don't well ship into traffic finances
how do you spend your money to carry
yourself in your health diet exercise
attitude and stay involved retiring that
should be one of the most exhilarating
ethics in
sighs and I do believe that I have a
husband retired recently and I don't
think that he worked for the same
company for potty seven years was very
happy in his work and was very happy
when he retired because he was ready and
he was ready to move on and that was
probably the team his health he was
diagnosed with prostate cancer two
months after his retirement and Dell
through it he is to me an example of
someone who has self-actualized whose
father where he wants to be in his very
happy day that's my definition of
self-actualization we ought to tell you
that the possibilities are nearly
endless and I wish you the best in
creating elbow thank you yes thank you
um thanks everybody for coming I think
we're right at five thirty so if you if
you want to ask a few questions that's
fine but I think we'll probably just go
ahead and wrap up the formal um program
are there any just short brief questions
not a question which is common I agree
that you don't necessarily
membership but it is a nice short memory
yeah we have access to a wonderful gym
and for three bucks you can get a
consultation with China and you can be
given thread our course you want to do
better but but they were tiny goal all
of these different Beatitudes know in
civil service and many of the insurance
companies will paint you can join a gym
salt for those of you for whatever
reason don't don't come to memory campus
you can go to a curves it's for women
only but it's free with many insurances
and also a balance and the fitness will
take insurance in not charging to
encourage and I think we're planning is
one real strength training is is
probably one of the best things that you
can do that's why I suggested even if
you can't get out is to sit in the chair
get a couple of five pound bags of rice
or beans and raise them constantly every
day that you're exercising when the bag
without hope them and get another one
but and that's very good for you because
that's a compound carbohydrate there are
so many things that you can do and i saw
a rush to things and um no aging is to
me a remarkable opportunity I've lost
too many friends before they were old
and all of us have and all of us have
seen things happen and i think that the
privilege we have is living in a time
a lot of study on aging and we know that
that it's something that's an
opportunity was there for all of us to
take advantage I just wanted to add
another opportunity specifically at
Emory someone brought up at the last
session mark the center for health
discovery and well-being there's
brochures out on the table they are very
involved in being proactive about
healthcare issues and if you really want
to i'm going to get a fuller
understanding of your particular space
on the health continuum and how you can
move towards the wellness I more
effectively than that would be a good
place to start I want to thank you again
Louis for coming and thank you all for
joining us if again if you're interested
in coming to the next one please don't
hesitate to fill out a registration form
we'd love to have you here if you're not
already signed up but
the preceding program is copyrighted by
Emory University